also this morning a move that could
affect a fight against Isis in Iraq in a
controversial and some say illegal vote
90% of Iraqi Kurds who have been
America's closest partners in the fight
have voted for independence from the
Iraqi government that is set off a
series of backlash and retaliations
Holly Williams is in the Kurdish capital
of Irbil Holly good morning Iraqi Kurds
from this region have been some of
America's closest partners in the fight
against Isis but they're now feeling the
consequences of their vote for
independence including the cancellation
of international flights military drills
on their border and threats from the
Iraqi national government to deploy
troops the last international flights
out of Iraqi Kurdistan left yesterday as
Iraq's national government ratchets up
the pressure pushing Kurdish authorities
to cancel the result of their referendum
voters in Iraqi Kurdistan most of them
members of the Kurdish ethnic minority
overwhelmingly chose full independence
on Monday they already rule over their
own autonomous region but Iraq national
government says the vote was illegal and
the referendum angered neighboring
Turkey and Iran both countries have
Kurdish populations that dream of
Independence the u.s. also opposed the
referendum worried it could disrupt the
fragile cooperation between the Kurds
and the Iraqi government in the fight
against Isis the Kurds of Iraq have
battled bravely against the extremists
close American allies who have laid down
blood to defeat the fanatics captain has
another Hassan lost both his legs to an
Isis bomb Bernardo jihad every morning
when I used to wake up it was like hell
he told us before I was supporting my
people and my nation but then I couldn't
have him support myself
many people here believe that sacrifice
makes Iraqi Kurdistan more deserving of
independence but not even its friends
seem to agree Turkey has threatened to
cut off Iraqi Kurdistan's oil exports in
retaliation for the referendum and that
could be crippling because this region
is almost entirely dependent on oil
revenue for CBS this morning Saturday
Holly Williams Erbil